لكن مشاهدينا هناك اهميه ابعد لاتفاق
تصدير الحبوب والمطالبه الروسيه المتعلقه
بالسميدتها فموسكو تعد اكبر مصدر للاسمده
في العالم بحسب
الاحصاءات اغلب الصادرات هذه تتوجه الى
البرازيل والهند والصين واستونيا وغيرها
من الدول لكن الاسمده الروسيه باتت موطئ
قدم للتحالف السياسي بين روسيا ودول
افريقيه وعلى راسها جمهوريه مالاوي العام
الماضي وافقت روسيا على التبرع ب 260 الف
طن من الاسمده للدول الافريقيه الاكثر
عرضه لخطر انعدام الامن الغذائي مالاوي
كانت احدى هذه الدول المستقبله للاسمده
وخاصه تلك المتبرعه بها واستقبلت الشهر
الماضي عشرين الف طن هذه الدوله استعانت
بشركه الكيماويات الروسيه اوراكليم
والتي يخضع مؤسسها لعقوبات غربيه وزير
الزراعه الملاوي اشاد بالتبرع الروسي وقال
ان الوالدات الاخيره من روسيا ستساعد في
انتاج 800,000 طن من الذره واطعام 400 الف
اسره الدعم الروسي ذو الاهميه بالنسبه
لملاوي خاصه ان 80% من مواطنيها يعتمدون
بشكل كامل او شبه كامل على الزراعه